aber die hier erzählt einfach immer
weiter runter und ich habe jetzt durch
diesen bank mehr oder weniger unendlich
vielen diamant blog freunde
haltet euch fest kummer 5er toppt alles
der maschinen- und herzlich willkommen
zu einer kuh im loch herzlich willkommen
zu einer kuh in einer kuh letztlich will
kommt seiner folge minecraft wieso
schreibst sowie susanne thon ich nur so
aus aber lastwagen diesel ist ihr sohn
pedes gebaut mit musik ensemble ist
endlos heute schon wieder also herzlich
willkommen zu den microsoft command ich
bin mega gut drauf und fährt dann direkt
wieder ein bus von natur her muss wissen
die busse hier in der umgebung der mir
vor der tür erfahren
die denkt sich einfach so ja
wahrscheinlich einfach auf wurde aber
wahrscheinlich steigen aber nie wir
befinden uns hier in einer weiteren
folge der minecraft command wo ich mir
gedacht regeln wir können jetzt schon
öfter kommt so ein format wie minecraft
kommerz vorgestellt werden habe ich doch
nicht so gesehen es wird von euch so gut
angenommen jedem schickt mir so viele
command zu und ich muss da nicht zehn
jahre lang lang suchen bis ich was ich
liebe euch einfach und ich habe es
richtig cool gefunden und wir fangen
einfach an mit command nummer festival
wird mir zugesendet für den kleinen pitt
hätten ihr seht schon ich müsste mich
hier gerade so ein bisschen aus und zwar
ist das ein command den ich auch schon
mal damals in den facts vorgestellt habe
allerdings war es halt damals folge und
jetzt ist die kommas das heißt ich nehme
ich natürlich noch mal dran weil er
einfach cool ist und zwar ist es dieser
command / game ruhl unter leerzeichen
random tick speed leerzeichen
wenn ich jetzt mal auf enter drücken
also der wird nämlich zugesendet von
basti also was die idee ist natürlich
von mir eigentlich der command aber der
bastille haben den google blendet und
jetzt singt man denken was verändert das
denn jetzt schaut mal wenn ich jetzt
gesetzlichen setzte
im moment war das ein tropenbaum setzte
in den schwarz reichen setzen ihren
sätzen einem tick speed 10.000 mache ich
mal rein theoretisch wie so happy end of
love your hands
eine neue welt neues glück ich gebe
momente ich liebe diesen command an
und wenn ich jetzt einen setzling
hinsetze seht ihr schon der baum wächst
einfach direkt das ist nämlich ein game
room ändert die spielregel wie schnell
dinge wachsen wenn ich jetzt hier
einfach mal rein theoretisch so ein
bisschen drüber fliege und ich erzähle
einfach mal so ein paar setzlinge hin
sie die schon die wachsen richtig
schnell einfach bäume nach noch das
gleiche auch wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise einfach mal mit den
kürbiskernen und mit der frau und mit
dem wasser sammlers hinsetze und die
sätze ja mal die kürbiskerne hindernis
könnt ihr schon sehen dass die einfach
mega schnell hoch wachsen und die
kriegen auch jeden moment einfach dicke
kürbisse daran geklatscht das ist ein
mega cool alkomat den hab ich euch ja
schon ein bisschen habe ich euch ja
damals schon mal ein effekt folge
vorgestellt und zwar verändert der quasi
einfach so die spielregel wie schnell
etwas wächst ich weiß nicht wie hoch man
dagegen kann von der zahl ob man da bis
in die millionen gehen kann bin ich mir
nicht so sicher wie ihr seht ihr schon
innerhalb von 20 sekunden sind hier
diese ganzen kürbisse irgendwie
angefangen zu wachsen wir haben hier die
ganzen bäume ich dann schaut euch das
einfach mal an die sätze hier einen
setzling hin und wir haben einen neuen
baum also ich weiß gar nicht warum ich
darüber so aufrege aber ich weiß nämlich
damals schon mal vorgestellt habe aber
ich finde ihn immer noch ganz geil und
das auf jeden fall einer meiner
lieblings commands und der wurde mir
jetzt noch mal aufgeschnappt von basti
und jetzt kommt's endeffekt nur zwei l
command nummer zwei soll ganz ruhig
bleiben lokal bleibt euch bräuchten
gehört gerade schon freunde es ist keine
musik mehr dran weil ich gehe jetzt mal
diesen command ein jetzt hört mal ganz
genau was war das denn nicht noch mal
leute denke das war alles
moment mal ein gewitter habe angst fick
dich mit mir ich bin mir das einzige was
gemacht habe dass ich hab mich in den
boden gegraben und das klingt einfach
immer noch also das war auf jeden fall
nummer zwei wurde mit zugesendet von
einer anonymen person die anonym bleiben
möchte
die geräusche abspielen in minecraft
funktion und da muss man entweder diesen
command eingeben oder irgendwie den hier
und dann kann man das streamen also
überall dass jeder das hört und eine
welle und da gibt es auch commands dass
man da irgendwie denen den zaun voller
krieter explosion abspielen kann
und ich hab euch einfach erstmal nur die
beiden eine beschreibung aber es gibt
noch welche mit kripo sonst so da kann
er theoretisch einfach mal ihr könnt ihr
anstatt einfach irgendwie kontrakte
eingeben oder oder irgendwie weiß ich
nicht comedy und anwenden
daher steht dann hört der den sound von
einem krieg oder so das mega witzig kann
man auf den fall leute mit rollen und
das ist koman 22 abs
der dritte weg wurde mir
dann habe ich eigentlich alzey maria
dritte komme übrigens das sollte jetzt
kein witz über alzheimer sein ich kenne
selber leute die alzheimer haben das ist
natürlich überhaupt nicht witzig aber es
ist einfach nimmt das nicht ernst ich
habe auch letztes gewesen dass ich leute
darüber beschwert haben dass sich
teilweise das wort behindert benutzte
natürlich ist es nicht schön wehrleute
behindert sind aber ich meine ich bin ja
auch nicht gegen die leute also
vergessen wir das ganze wie sind die
beiden minecraft wollen ihr fröhlich
miteinander umgehen
das stellt übrigens kein hakenkreuz da
das ist einfach nur teil des romans
jetzt besser redstone schreibt da kriegt
man ein liegendes schwert raus und was
euch das ganze in etwa so anordnen
eigentlich das sogar nur so an orten
aber bei mir wird teilweise auch hier
gespart oder hier oder hier und wenn ich
jetzt hier beispielsweise einfach mal in
diesen befehls blog reingehe ich liebe
diesen langen befehl ein und ich klicke
auf so und guckt jetzt ist
beispielsweise hier wenn ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich wieder drauf drücken gc
jetzt geht es gerade aber jetzt habe ich
beispielsweise gerade einfach ein
liegendes schwert auf dem chris marine
block und das ist so gar nicht einfach
so dahin gelegt sondern wenn ihr mal
genauer schaut das ist sogar drei bin
ich richtig cool man kann mit so richtig
lang kommen was machen wir dann solche
animationen die wir vor ein paar folgen
schon mal hatten
finde ich richtig leistung kann dich
professor redstone und das ist auf jeden
fall command nummer 3 übrigens wenn ihr
commands hab ne wenn ihr solche coolen
command nicht so was wie man das in chat
schreibt dann wird das den anderen auch
angezeigt wenn ihr echt coole sachen
habt dann könnt ihr auf jeden fall indes
commands formular schreiben dass es
irgendwie in der beschreibung
eingeblendet da habe ich auch erst 5000
commands drin also es war 3 und jetzt
kommen command nummer in einfachen
letzter zeit so mega how i met your
mother süchtig ich weiß nicht warum ich
das grad sage na ja roman nummer 4 wurde
von cedric und zwar gibt man diese
command ja ein
jetzt drücke ich einfach mal so jetzt
kommt darum ein williger raus und das
ist kein normaler villiger sondern
dieser wille gehandelt mit mir im
minusbereich nicht jetzt mal hingehen
ökolöwe
wollen wir sache ich habe jetzt die
sonne
der block und wenn ich jetzt theoretisch
in diesem winter hier handle dann gehe
ich dem erde und er gibt mir - 24
diamant glück und wenn ich jetzt meinen
game mode 0 g und jetzt mal ein diamant
blog davon setzt oder so dann seht ihr
das geht weiter ins minus ich weiß nicht
warum weil man hat schon - teile aber
ich habe dementsprechend jetzt unendlich
diamant blöcke also wenn ihr diesen
command nimmt und diesem villagers
bonner den irgendwo im dorf setzt ihr
seht schon ich bin jetzt zwar schon bei
minus 69 und die zahl geht halt nicht
runter sondern normalerweise so dass es
bei minecraft so ist wenn die zahl bei
null ist dass er keine blöcke mehr aber
die hier erzählt einfach immer weiter
runter und ich habe jetzt durch diesen
bug mehr oder weniger unendlich vielen
diamant blöcke das ist auf jeden fall
ein richtig interessanter command das
einzige was ich weiß ist wenn ein
schwert wenn beim schwert unten 0 steht
dann kann ich damit nur noch einmal
schlafen dann ist kaputt aber mit den
diamant blöcken dass ich jetzt einfach
hoch addiert dann wusste jetzt auch
nicht ich weiß nicht wie oft man das
jetzt machen kann
es ist auf jeden fall ganz interessant
und das ist roman nummer 4 dank hatten
ich denke da werden einige leute sehr
sehr viel spaß mit hafen freunde
haltet euch fest komma 5er toppt alles
ich habe hier gerade einen troll army m
typ schaffen ohne witz ist quasi einfach
ein kombi mit seinem paar extra features
also der halbblut er so ein bisschen
zeit ein paar effekte der ist
beispielsweise auch wilde bilder und
kate und dadurch dass er diesen diesem
promi kopf hat verbrennt er nicht mein
tag und das ist jetzt quasi so mein
persönlicher throl zombie okay ich finde
es gerade nicht cool was was mit dem
abgeht du nein nein das ist eine
unendliche diamanten quelle den greifst
du nicht an
troll armin ein weg das ist doch nicht
wahr jetzt greift ihr hier auch noch
nein du lässt ihn in ruhe du kleiner
pisser weiter jetzt hat der meine
unendliche die hamas hätte ich die lange
da bot es lief also damit kann man quasi
einfach so einen control kombi spawnen
ich sehe schon wieder ich hab den ja so
laut schon wieder gewesen mit control
zombies tonne mit dem komma die komma
beschreibung und der hat dann eine treue
maske auf der perfekte und ist
eigentlich relativ schlecht aber das ist
einfach so ein witziger kommen
ja auch entweder ganz ganz sinnvoll
dokument oder in welche back home video
oder irgendwelche total behinderten
kontrolle gerade dann schreibt romans
formular link dazu in beschreibung drin
und natürlich sagen freunde bewerten
nicht vergessen dass ein kleiner klick
und wir sehen uns in der nächsten folge
wieder die irgendwann die tage kommt
ciao